Доброго дня. Вітаю вас
на уроці біології у 7 класі.
Звати мене Софія Михайлівна.
На попередньому уроці ми
вивчили з вами розмноження тварин.
Давайте пригадаємо, що таке розмноження?
Розмноження – це
відтворення собі подібних,
основна і одна з основних властивостей
всіх живих істот на планеті Земля,
які здатні передавати
генетичну інформацію.
Якщо характеризувати розмноження,
то розмноження має два типи.
Перший - це нестатеве, другий - статевий.
Що таке взагалі нестатеве розмноження?
Нестатеве розмноження –
бере участь одна особина,
яка може самостійно себе відтворювати.
До статевого розмноження
відноситься дві особини.
Під час статевого розмноження
відбувається злиття гамет
чоловічого і жіночого організму.
Які способи нестатевого
розмноження притаманні організмам?
Як ви пам’ятаєте, це
поділ навпіл, бінарний,
множинний поділ або шизогонія,
фрагментація та брунькування.
Якщо характеризувати статеве
розмноження, то статеве розмноження
має декілька типів, або способів.
Перший спосіб - поліембріонія,
наступний - гермафродитизм
та партеногенез.
Ми вже з вами багато знаєм
про різноманітність тварин.
Про їхнє пристосування до умов
навколишнього середовища, будову.
Але, скажіть мені, будь ласка,
чи пам’ятаєте ви себе в дитинстві?
Коли вам тільки декілька днів,
тижнів, місяців і навіть років.
А чи пам’ятає себе в
дитинстві комаха, плазун, птахи?
Особисто я можу відверто сказати, своє
дитинство до трьох років я не пам’ятаю.
Тема нашого уроку, як ви
зрозуміли: «Розвиток тварин».
Термін «онтогенез» вперше був
введений Ернестом Геккелем в 1866 році.
В ході онтогенезу відбувається
процес реалізації, генетичної інформації,
отриманої від батьків. Онтогенез,
ще раз наголошую – це індивідуальний
розвиток особини від її
народження до смерті.
Онтогенез поділяється на два
великих періоди – це ембріональний,
ще його називають зародковий, та
постембріональний або післязародковий.
В ембріональному розвитку
цікаво те, що організми розвиваються
всередині материнського,
або всередині яйця.
Постембріональний або післязародковий –
це вихід з яйцевих оболонок і народження.
Якщо характеризувати
постембріональний період,
він ділиться на два
види: прямий та непрямий.
Непрямий ми будемо
розглядати трошки далі.
Хочу звернути увагу, що непрямий
поділ ділиться на непрямий розвиток
з повним метаморфозом та непрямий
розвиток з неповним метаморфозом.
Давайте з вами розглянемо, які етапи
відбуваються всередині
ембріонального періоду.
Якщо характеризувати
ембріональний період, то ви пам’ятаєте -
це зародження всередині
материнського організму.
Завершальним етапом ембріонального
розвитку є вихід з яйцевих оболонок.
Наприклад, це плазуни, птахи. А
народження притаманне ссавцям.
Якщо характеризувати основні
етапи ембріонального періоду,
вони поділяються на дробіння,
гаструляцію, гістогенез та органогенез.
Давайте розглянемо з вами
етапи ембріогенезу хордових тварин.
Перший етап – це
дробіння. Що таке дробіння?
Це коли зигота мітотично ділиться, а
клітини (їх називають бластомерами)
в інтерфазі не збільшуються.
Подивіться, будь ласка,
що утворюється під час
поділу два бластомера,
чотири, вісім, шістнадцять,
тридцять два і так далі.
Бластомери сконцентровані
у вигляді сфери, кулі.
Групи бластомерів
утворюють всередині порожнину
і закладається зовнішній шар
ектодерми. Організм є одношаровим.
Наступним періодом після утворення
бластули - формується процес гаструляція.
Як ви бачите на слайді,
відбувається впинання
зовнішніх клітин всередину зародка
і утворюється двошаровий
зародок з ендодермою.
Якщо характеризувати цей
процес, то, звичайно, таким процесам
притаманні такі представники,
як губки та кишковопорожнинні.
Наступне - формується третій зародковий
листок, який називається – мезодерма.
Зверніть, будь ласка, увагу,
що мезодерма – це середній шар.
З чого утворюється мезодерма,
ектодерма, ендодерма?
Які органи, та системи органів?
Якщо характеризувати ектодерму,
то з ектодерми формується
нервова трубка, зовнішні
зябра, органи чуття.
До ендодерми відноситься:
плавальний міхур, хорда, внутрішні зябра.
Із мезодерми формується скелет,
кровоносна система, перикард.
Якщо говорити про наступний
етап, утворення гістогенезу,
це утворення тканин, та органогенезу.
Як ви вже зрозуміли, утворення
органів та систем органів.
В ембріональному розвитку органогенез
має найбільш швидкі зміни і
закінчується, але є декілька клітин,
які диференціюються і змінюються
ще і в постембріональному розвитку.
Наступний етап, як ви вже
зрозуміли, найбільший і найоб’ємніший –
це постембріональний
період, або після зародковий.
Постембріональний період –
це вихід з яйцевих оболонок
або народження організму
до статевої зрілості.
Якщо характеризувати цей період,
організми є найбільш вразливими,
і якщо батьки не піклуються
про своє потомство,
то молоді особини вірогідно загинуть.
В постембріональному розвитку
під час дозрівання статевої системи
деяким організмам притаманне
розмноження безперервно,
наприклад, паразитичним червам.
Один раз в своєму житті -
це однопрохідні або вугор,
а є такі представники, які тільки декілька
разів відкладають яйця. Це черепахи, щука.
До постембріонального етапу
відноситься прямий розвиток.
Прямий розвиток – це розвиток,
при якому щойно народжена тварина
загалом нагадує дорослу,
хоча значно менша за розмірами.
У цей час організм може відносно
самостійно існувати і живитися.
Цікавий прямий розвиток тим,
що щойно народжена особина,
хоч і схожа на материнську,
але в неї погано розвинені,
як ви вже зрозуміли, органи,
які відповідають за розмноження.
Вона росте, розвивається,
збільшується у розмірах,
але все ж таки неподібна
до дорослої особини.
Зверніть увагу, що такі представники
відносяться до прямого розвитку:
гідра прісноводна, дощовий черв,
річковий рак і, звичайно, молюск.
Якщо характеризувати
види прямого розвитку,
до нього відноситься
справжнє живонародження.
Цікаве тим, що справжнє живонародження
пов’язане з розвитком зародка,
який знаходиться всередині материнського,
живиться поживними її речовинами.
Як ви вже зрозуміли –
це плацентарні ссавці.
Наступний вид називається
яйцеживонародження.
Яйцеживонародження – це розвиток
зародка всередині материнського,
але споживання поживних речовин з яйця.
Деякі ящірки, змії та акваріумні рибки.
Наступний тип – яйценародження.
Як ви зрозуміли, що зародок
розвивається поза межами материнського,
але споживає поживні речовини
яйця і сам проживає там.
До них відносяться птахи та плазуни.
Біологічне значення прямого
розвитку полягає в тому,
що організм є менш вразливим до зовнішніх
чинників навколишнього середовища.
Наступний тип післязародкового
розвитку – непрямий.
Що таке непрямий розвиток?
Непрямий розвиток – це розвиток,
при якому утворюється личинка,
що перетворюється на дорослу особину
безпосередньо або через перетворення.
Зверніть, будь ласка, увагу,
що при непрямому розвитку
особина не схожа на материнську,
і їй потрібно пройти декілька фаз
для того, щоб розмножуватись.
Якщо характеризувати непрямий
розвиток, то він ділиться на такі види:
непрямий розвиток з повним перетворенням
і непрямий розвиток з
неповним перетворенням.
Сьогодні ми будемо з вами
розглядати і характеризувати,
які ознаки і фази притаманні
повному та неповному перетворенню.
Сьогодні хочу вам охарактеризувати
непрямий розвиток, а саме, розвиток жаби.
Цей розвиток цікавий тим, що
розмножуються жаби в водному середовищі,
є роздільностатевими та в
більшості запліднення зовнішнє.
Як відбувається
розмноження і розвиток жаб?
По-перше, коли настає весна, жаби
прокидаються від зимового заціпеніння.
Якщо охарактеризувати самку і самця,
то вони починають шукати водойму.
Водойма швидко прогрівається
сонячним випромінюванням
і самки починають відкладати ікринки.
Самець підпливаючи до ікринки,
виділяє рідину, яка містить сперматозоїди.
Так відбувається розмноження.
А як відбувається розвиток?
Якщо подивитись на
слайд, то під номером один
ікринки мають зовнішню оболонку
у вигляді драглистої речовини,
яка захищає ікринку від
зовнішніх подразників.
Вона набухає і уловлює
сонячне випромінювання.
Навіщо для ікринки
сонячне випромінювання?
Для того, щоб підтримувати
температуру всередині.
Вночі драглиста оболонка утримує вищу
температуру, ніж температура у водоймі.
Як ви бачите, ікринка всередині
містить пігмент чорного кольору.
Навіщо він там? Цей пігмент
уловлює сонячне випромінювання,
за допомогою якого
відбувається розвиток ікринки.
Якщо характеризувати наступний етап,
який відбувається в ікринці
– це утворення личинки.
Личинка за зовнішнім виглядом
відрізняється від ікринки тим,
що вона має хвіст, бічну лінію,
зовнішні зябра, двокамерне серце
та одне коло кровообігу, що має
спільні ознаки з кістковими рибами.
У личинки, або в пуголовка
відбуваються певні перетворення
і він стає схожим на дорослу особину.
В першу чергу у личинки
відбувається коротшання хвоста.
Утворюються кінцівки, замість зовнішніх
- зябра, утворюються внутрішні зябра.
Як ви бачите, на п’ятій стадії утворюється
молода особина, яку називають жабеня.
Жабеня знаходиться два-три
місяці у водному середовищі.
Звичайно, через деякий час може
виходити на суходіл і там розвиватися.
Статевозрілими дорослі
особини стають на третій рік життя.
Ой, який непростий розвиток у
них з непрямим перетворенням.
Але є ще один цікавий
вид, який пов’язаний
з неповним та повним перетворенням.
Хочу вам нагадати, що до непрямого
розвитку відноситься два види –
це непрямий розвиток з
повним метаморфозом
та прямий розвиток з
неповним метаморфозом.
До непрямого розвитку
з повним метаморфозом
відносяться у нас такі
представники, наприклад, як комахи.
Ви пам’ятаєте, що комахи
налічують понад один мільйон видів.
Їхнє тіло поділено на
голову, груди і черевце.
На голові сконцентровано чотири сегмента.
На грудях три, від яких
відходять парні кінцівки та крила
і, звичайно, черевце, яке складається
з шести до дванадцяти члеників.
Якщо характеризувати непрямий розвиток з
повним перетворенням або метаморфозом,
ми будемо з вами розглядати
такого представника,
як метелик, який відноситься
до ряду лускокрилих.
Якщо подивитись на фазу, то,
звичайно, ці фази відрізняються між собою.
Зверніть, будь ласка,
увагу, що метелик має яйце.
З якого відкладається личинка,
яка за зовнішнім виглядом
відрізняється від дорослої особини.
Між ними не відбувається конкуренції,
тому що гусінь або личинка
споживає рослинну їжу.
Доросла особина імаго,
споживає нектар квітів.
Наступна фаза – це лялечка.
Лялечка – це стадія спокою.
Як ви вже зрозуміли,
тварина всередині не живиться,
а її органи, система
органів перетворюються,
змінюються на дорослу особину.
Яким представникам притаманний
непрямий розвиток з повним перетворенням?
Це ряд двокрилі, комарі,
мухи, ряд перетинчастокрилі,
бджоли, мурашки, ряд твердокрилі,
жук-олень, сонечко.
Всі ці прекрасні створіння
мають певні морфологічні ознаки,
які ми будемо далі з вами
розглядати в наступних параграфах.
Непрямий розвиток з неповним
перетворенням або метаморфозом
притаманний, наприклад, ряду прямокрилі
(перелітна сарана, коники, цвіркуни),
ряду воші, ряду клопи або напівтвердокрилі
і ряду рівнокрилі (попелиця).
Зверніть увагу, що ми з вами розглядаємо
цикл розвитку з перетворенням коника.
Самка відкладає яйця, з яєць вилуплюються
схожі на материнський
організм представник,
але він має недорозвинені крила.
Через деякий час коник
починає живитися, збільшуватись,
але хітинізований покрив
не дає йому цю можливість,
тому у коника відбувається
явище – линяння.
Коли коник скидає свій
хітинізований панцир,
то під ним знаходиться тонка
кутикула, яка розтягується,
і після того коник може
збільшуватись у розмірі.
Коник линяє декілька разів, і після
того настає процес статевого дозрівання.
Біологічне значення непрямого
розвитку, або з метаморфозом
пов’язане з декількома функціями.
Перша функція – це живильна.
Живильна функція характерна для
всіх представників, які мають певні фази.
На кожній фазі організм живиться,
збільшується та удосконалює
органи та системи органів
за рахунок поживних речовин.
Наступна функція – це
раціональне використання ресурсів.
Основна функція третя - розселювальна.
Якщо говорити про цю функцію, то
ви знаєте, що багато представників
мають прикріплений спосіб життя,
можуть бути малорухливими або активними.
За допомогою течій, за допомогою
вітру відбувається розселення
великої кількості та різноманітності
видів на певні території.
Давайте узагальнемо та систематизуємо
знання, які ми отримали на уроці.
Розглянемо слайд з
запитанням. Увага на екран.
Як ви пам’ятаєте, що з прямим розвитком -
це утворення організму,
схожого до материнського,
а непрямий – повинні відбутися певні
фази для того, щоб організм став дорослим.
Розглянемо яким представникам
притаманний прямий розвиток.
До прямого розвитку відноситься?
Це кабан дикий, хрящова риба
скат та, звичайно, ластівка сільська.
До непрямого – сонечко, жук,
цвіркун та ряд лускокрилі, метелик.
Підсумуємо.
Індивідуальний розвиток
організму багатоклітинних тварин
складається із зародкового
та післязародкового періоду.
Під час зародкового періоду
утворюються багатоклітинна тварина,
яка послідовно проходить етапи
одношарового, двошарового,
а більше - тришарового зародку,
формування тканин та органів.
Післязародковий розвиток
може бути прямим і непрямим.
У разі непрямого розвитку
народжуються личинка,
яка за будовою, а часто і за способом
життя, відрізняється від дорослої.
Біологічне значення непрямого розвитку
полягає у здійснені таких
функцій, як живильна.
У комах живильною фазою є гусінь.
Раціональне використання
ресурсів, різні фази розвитку
розділенні за способами
і об’єктами живлення.
Розселення: личинки багатьох малорухливих
видів здатні до активного переміщення.
У разі прямого розвитку
народжується молода особина,
яка схожа до батьківської.
Біологічне значення прямого розвитку
полягає в тому, що
організми є менш вразливими
до зовнішніх чинників
навколишнього середовища.
Зверніть увагу та відкрийте підручник
на сторінці з темою: «Розвиток тварин».
Дякую за увагу! Будьте здорові!